ya estamos muy acostumbrados a utilizar
los operadores de suma de resta de
multiplicación y de división incluso
hasta tenemos otros símbolos para estos
dos pero lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es algo mucho más divertido quiero
que aprendamos a definir nuestros
propios operadores esto nos va a ayudar
a ver lo amplio que son las matemáticas
y en un sentido un poco más práctico nos
va a ayudar a resolver problemas que
vienen en algunos exámenes
estandarizados pero vaya incluso estos
problemas que vienen en los exámenes
estandarizados tienen detrás una idea
después de que veamos que estos cuatro
no son los únicos operadores sino que en
realidad podemos definir muchos más
entonces déjame empezar con este ejemplo
voy a definir x diamante y x diamante y
como 5 x 5 x menos y entonces la idea es
que esto es más o menos como una función
solo que ahora le vamos a meter dos
valores x
y de regreso nos va a dar la expresión
5x menos como como es una función que
depende de dos valores se conoce
un operador entonces con esta definición
imagínate que nos piden determinar
cuánto es 77 diamante 11 diamante 11
bueno entonces lo que tenemos que hacer
es aquí cambiar todas las equis por 7 y
todas las 10 por 11 entonces este 7 va
para acá este 11 va para acá entonces
nos quedaría 5 por 7 déjame ponerlo con
color naranja de del 75 por 7 - y
llévale 11 entonces sería menos -11 muy
bien y con esto ya podemos hacer las
operaciones 5 por 7 35 y 35 bueno lo voy
a hacer poco a poco es 35 35 eso quedó
un poco feo de japón el 5 más bonito ya
eso tenemos que restar 11 35 menos 11 es
igual a 24 y por lo tanto 7 diamante y
es igual a 24 simplemente sustituimos y
realizamos las operaciones déjame hacer
otro ejemplo aquí a la derecha vamos a
poner
a definir la operación
estrella de estrella ve muy bien
entonces a estrella ve va a ser igual a
a entre más me ahorita lo estoy
inventando si en realidad hay mucha
flexibilidad podemos pudimos haber dicho
que esto era pues casi cualquier cosa
voy a ponerle que es a entre ambas ve
entonces imagínate que ahora nos piden
determinar 55 estrella 65 estrella
estrella lo voy a poner también con
verde cinco estrellas 6 muy bien
entonces esto aquí sería igual pues a
vale 5 y bbva le 6 simplemente
sustituimos 5 en cada lugar donde haya
una y 6 en cada lugar donde haya un ave
entonces nos quedaría 5 / dividido entre
5 5 + 6 y realizamos las operaciones
aquí está muy sencillito arriba nos
queda 5 y abajo nos queda 11 566 11 y
por lo tanto 5 estrellitas 6 5
muy bien ahora también podemos componer
ambas operaciones pero al componer las
tenemos que utilizar paréntesis porque
todavía no hemos decidido si primero va
la operación de amante o si primero va
la operación estrella déjame poner un
ejemplo para ver a qué me refiero
imagínate que nos piden determinar cuál
es el valor de no sé de menos uno menos
uno
diamante diamante
y aquí voy a poner el paréntesis que te
digo cero estrella 5
una vez más el paréntesis es importante
porque no conocemos el orden de las
operaciones aquí arriba sabemos que la
multiplicación va antes que la suma pero
aquí abajo no sabemos y estrellaba antes
que diamante bueno entonces vamos a
realizar esta operación vale esta
composición de operaciones como como
aquí hay un paréntesis vamos a empezar
con eso de ahí vamos a hacer primero 0
estrellas 5 entonces vamos a la
definición de estrella a es 0 v 5 nos
quedaría 0 entre 0 + 5 muy bien cero
entre cualquier cosa que no sea cero es
cero entonces estoy aquí es cero y por
lo tanto ahora esta expresión es igual
es igual a menos uno diamante diamante
cero diamantes cero muy bien ahora sí
como ya tenemos una una cosa en términos
de la operación diamantes nos vamos para
acá x vale menos uno y vale cero
entonces nos quedaría cinco por equis
5 x menos 1 y a eso tenemos que restarle
0 5 x menos 1 es menos 5 menos 5 igual
no restar 0 no es hacer nada entonces
nos queda menos 5 y por lo tanto este es
el resultado de nuestra composición de
operaciones vale bueno la idea general
es que te sientas cómodo definiendo
nuevos operadores no hay que espantarse
si de repente te encuentras un diamante
por ahí si te dan la definición de
diamante entonces sabes exactamente qué
hacer para evaluarlo
simplemente sustituye los valores en el
orden correspondiente vale bueno estos
son algunos ejemplos sencillos déjame
hacer un poco más raro porque puedes ver
cosas más extrañas aunque no entren
tanto en el mundo de los operadores es
más o menos la misma idea
imagínate que de repente alguien decide
definir esta cosa extraña que es el
diamante mayor aquí voy a poner un
diamante grandote o el gran diamante
vamos a llamar el gran diamante entonces
imagínate que alguien te define gran
diamante para cuatro números
b c y d y te dicen sabes qué gran
diamante de abc d es igual a a de menos
b dividido en 13
entonces otra vez no hay que espantarse
esto simplemente es una definición y
justo esta igualdad nos dice cómo
podemos tratar a diamante mayor al gran
diamante entonces ahora pues esa misma
persona te podría pedir que que
encontrarás el valor de gran diamante
gran diamante
no se ha dejado ponerle por aquí algunos
números de menos 1 5 3 y 2 por decir
algo entonces simplemente lo que hay que
hacer es ver cuál es el valor de cada
uno de estos números a qué a qué letra
corresponden y substituir para no
hacerme bolas déjame ponerle que éste es
a éste se ve este c y éste es de y
entonces ahora sí con esto en mente
tenemos que hacer a por d es decir menos
uno por dos menos uno por dos y eso
tenemos que restarle b o sea restarle 5
y luego tenemos que dividir tenemos que
dividir en 13 aquí tenemos que es 3
cuanto nos da menos 1 por 2 es menos 2 -
2 - 5 entre 3 y menos dos menos 5 es
igual a menos 7 por lo tanto nos queda
menos 7 tercios ok entonces esto de aquí
parecía muy espantoso al inicio había un
gran diamante pero no hay que
preocuparse simplemente con la
definición podemos trabajar
un gran diamante vale bueno lo que te
recomiendo ahorita es jugar un poco y de
hecho hacer tus propias operaciones
diviértete un ratito a tus propias
operaciones y ve qué cosas interesantes
puedes encontrar